hey it's Scarlett Johansson and we have
been hard at work on the new film ghost
in the shell' we are finally ready to
give you a look at it I am thrilled to
have been given the opportunity to play
the major and I'm so excited to be able
to show you a glimpse into her world I
hope you enjoy this special look at
ghost in the shell' this is Major
I'm going in we saved you and now you
save others then you're not invulnerable
maybe next time you can design me better
jinkies oh come on geez
they did not save your life
this dollars
so Julie Johnson they created me but
they cannot control me
Sangha says she boom coochie don't bleep
[Music]
watch here you'll have to remember I saw
someone down there
it wasn't human
he's a known terrorist and he's killed
again
they didn't just kill them I hacked into
their minds was everywhere I know where
I will find him and I'm killing
you never talk about their past
knowledge it was fragments there was an
attack you were dying
we saved you and now you save others
everything they told you was a lie you
had a family
remember that
what are you
what a beauty you are
what do you want for me
they did not save your life they stole
it
how many were there before me
she was supposed to have a clean-burning
my order you determinate
make up
they created me but they cannot control
me
you
you